nobody on this earth has ever
counterfeited more money than I did and
better than I did
it's what it is it comes out like I'm
the self-proclaimed but it's not what I
am I don't say it the people say it and
it's true I looked it up it's true my
name is uh Frank Willis ah I'm from a
little town called Twilight's and Quebec
Canada what I did basically are free
money you know I just started with you
know stolen clothes and then it evolved
into car parks and then into stolen cars
as a whole we're all scrambling to make
money and find the next idea or whatever
why just let's skip all of that and just
make my old money directly this is when
I launched them to the Caliphate I mean
we did go to the moon so you know I
figured you know I can make this work
yeah to get from not knowing to how it's
actually done you can go on many sites
and most of that means this is funny but
most of them are government sites you
get from one sheet of paper to you know
ten different criteria that you had to
look into so you're moving forward from
the government websites it's how it
starts really single most complicated
things is the crispiness of the bill and
then you got the watermark is just a
matter of putting this up to the light
and then you can see the UV strip here
then you get the color shifting xx and
the color shifting eagle the fonts on
the serial number are provision fonts
and the the feel of the raised ink and
then you got the starch which you have
to neutralize it's actually very very
difficult to duplicate so yeah you have
to make it good if you wanted to if you
want to pass I'd say 75% of the security
of the currency is the paper it's up it
took me a whole year just to figure that
out the ingredients and the suppliers
and the
you know how and the different security
features included within the paper so
while I looked at you know hundreds of
suppliers something plain just hung up
on me and some told me flat out day
you're making you know paper for
banknotes with that and now we wrote it
down to the one that felt right to me G
with the smell or feeling so I picked
one and it went well another really
important part that that I had to really
make sure that was fully secure this one
I received a paper the order can be can
be bugged and police can be on it so we
sweep everything everything came out
good and clean once the paper was inside
my printing shop then I knew I had it
they were actual currency they were
banknotes that was printing from that on
that was really really cool I
successfully been able to sell money for
for about a year there's how long it
took before the sadly enough we sold he
to an undercover agent and the whole
thing came crashing down that was the
end of it my god arrested and I gave
them two hundred million and fake
currency that I had left plus a printing
press that they wanted so I gave that
away in exchange for they would remove
any accusation against me for
counterfeiting and I was fined $1,500 I
printed two hundred and fifty million
before I even sold one I gave back two
hundred million
so you do the math
[Music]
[Music]